speeding has long been an issue here
across the valley especially following a
number of recent deadly crashes and now
many parents are raising concerns about
drivers who simply do not follow the
rules inside our local school zones good
evening thanks for staying with us here
at 6 30. i'm denise faldis and i'm brian
loftis speeding long been a concern
really across the valley especially
following a number of recent deadly
crashes so now our parents are wondering
what can be done to make sure their kids
are safer around school zones mary jane
belliesa shares a new push from local
leaders
school zones have a limit of 15 miles
per hour the fines for speeding in a
school zone is double the amount of a
regular ticket but aaron breen the
director of road equity alliance at unlv
says stricter laws need to be in place
the disconnect that we have is that
officers do write that ticket currently
but there are times when it gets thrown
out of court because it's not its own
separate law we want there to be a
specific statute that calls you out just
like the regular speeding statute does
that will say
0
to 10 miles over and 11 to 20 miles over
carlos morales walks his daughter home
from school and says drivers are often
distracted driving through school zones
and i would say if you're distracted by
your phone
to not see blinking yellow lights you're
potentially not going to be able to see
kids who are crossing the road jessica
wagner says she feels it's much safer to
drop her son off at the front of the
school to avoid speedy drivers it's a
big problem
and
you know the police can't always be here
to make sure that people follow the
rules
so oftentimes
the kids are are
in the hands of you know our our
crossing guards and
they take the first steps out onto that
road and not everyone respects those
signs and slows down all traffic
offenses are misdemeanor criminal
violations right now come january 2023
they will be civil fines with no jail
time mary jane bullies live local now